[Music]
Kiernan man
diehard hundred october and predator
even without the last action here on
13th warrior and Thomas Crown Affair he
should be a legend and it's a sin that
he's not by ception also pretending to
be adversaries when you're really
friends measuring their dicks just for
the benefit of the audience cliche
what's the matter the CIA got to pushing
too many pencils are they really
armwrestling in midair have you ever
tried that it's nearly impossible
it's like Ernie saw over the top four
months before this came out and couldn't
help himself channel my team always
Brooks alone you know that I'm afraid we
all have our orders measures and that
game works well if Arnie's team lives by
its rules it turns down this job and we
have no movie so of course they have to
accept any and all last-minute
stipulations Arnold Apollo Creed Jesse
the body man this was kind of the
Expendables before the Expendables felt
the need to exist also Arnie and the
body two future governors were together
in two movies this year including the
running man it's like 1987 was giving a
terrible warning to California and
Minnesota that only Elon Musk could have
figured out but he was only 16 and
nobody listened the best jungle
camouflage is face makeup designed to
make you look like a wrought iron fence
that is half way through being knocked
over who's out backup no such thing old
buddy
what kind of elite crew Strike Force
alpha unit Rangers seal Delta team thing
doesn't maybe sort out these details I
don't know before the mission begins
okay if this is I black to help with
glare from the Sun like baseball players
use you've gone too far if this is like
Robert Downey jr. and Tropic Thunder
you've gone way too far
bunch of slack-jawed ladies and
gentlemen the former governor of the
great state of Minnesota no one will be
seated during the barely visible walking
through the jungle portion of the movie
anything to you was just another rebel
Patrol cool cool cool is anyone gonna
mention the pirate plank behind you 50
yards up in the air because it's super
obvious and man-made utterly demands you
comment on it show off literally landed
15 minutes ago
I'm pretty sure your water supply is
doing just fine no need to bear grylls
the local wildlife so quickly
I knew this man seems likely also didn't
the dog tag say seee hopper maybe old
Jim is just fine knocking back some
brews somewhere and poor Calvin Ezekiel
hopper got predators instead hey no
listen a soldier's done ain't no way for
anyone to die dude why would any small
band of soldiers need this much fuckin
grain so mister said I hate to feel dumb
he saw a guy like chopping wood to look
out to the nest some guys eating and a
headshot assassination but he did not
see any fuel dumps yes there is one but
he doesn't know that and neither do any
of the rest of these guys Dutch sets the
truck rolling into the camp with a bomb
on it but no one ever sees him or looks
back to see where the truck came from
and how convenient for him that the old
ass truck that isn't even being used as
a truck anymore still has perfect
alignment and continues straight into
its target why did you guys even plan
anything when you had a grenade launcher
just fire a dozen grenades in here sort
it all out later Jesus and yes there's a
hostage they want to save but I'll be
damned if anything they've done so far
shows any regard for the life of that
hostage they don't even know where the
hostage is apparently Carl Weathers is a
great ventriloquist because I didn't see
his lips move an inch when he said that
I swear to god no one in this scene
filled this scene on the same day that
the subtitles for this movie keep
switching between telling me these
guerillas are speaking Spanish and
Russia like they aren't even trying to
tell me what the English would be they
just keep saying speaking Spanish and
speaking Russian why even tell me the
language they're speaking if I don't get
to know the words also why hasn't the
predator killed any of these mother he
took out an entire other team of
American Special Forces sent here to
save the hostages but what the Predators
don't know these Russian Spanish
assholes are here okay fine let's
foolishly say he was strong enough to
stay upright with the kind of recoil
that BFG would kick back still that kind
of minigun spits out up to 6,000 rounds
per minute not only are there not nearly
enough shells on the ground but
considering we see this gun firing for
about two minutes during this butcher
block bloodbath but twelve thousand
rounds of ammunition alone would have
weighed almost 900 pounds also this type
of gun is so powerful it usually needs
its own dedicated power source to
operate much like my college girlfriends
yeah screenwriter knows this may be the
director too but this character sure
does not know this knock knock who's
there I'm a I'm a who I'm gonna go ahead
and say if you take the time to deliver
a lame joke two armed men before
shooting them that they will shoot you
first orange you glad I didn't say
banana but if this Central American I'm
a goddamn chatham too much racism there
for me to even unpacked sit at three
times and let's move on no traces get
them
ready to move i'm arnold schwarzenegger
and this is my thinking face the old how
much it appears as if i'm thinking son
of a bitch is dug in like an Alabama
tick you mean Nick Saban I may not have
explained the ball their surveillance
says we got you realize over the place
we never see any more gorillas the rest
of the film just FYI this guy has the
stabbing sensitivity of data from Star
Trek The Next Generation how did he
expertly stab the scorpion well not
stabbing any of this guy shirt or flesh
exactly how many times has he done this
before I'm Sonny Landon and this is my
laughter noise behold how much it sounds
as if I am laughing over a minute and 12
seconds of predator vision which is
basically black screen with some
sporadic thermal splotches barfed up
onto the image this is basically
blindness if you ask me when seeing only
heat signatures and hearing only garbled
audio put you at a fairly large
disadvantage overall this movie is 85%
people silently walking through the
woods while tense music plays also don't
you kind of get the sense that predator
is being with them to easily dispatch
the team scent before but he's been
watching them since they are on but
instead of laser offing these kill
mongers he's just watching the march
through the jungle he's like a horror
movie ghost hang around for a while
instead of just immediately killing the
ones needing killing yes it's nothing
major it's nothing
comma major or it's nothing major
laziest escape attempt ever basically
she might as well have blown air on the
guy or tickled him great whistle by
Arnold here let's slow that down and
admire how he makes that noise without
ever once even moving his lips
why is predator making these clicking
noises and giving away its position
right before it attacks ah red paint
this is your flood ah do you know that
take a look at this you better take a
look at this cliche just look at
Arnold's outfit here its pristine
no sign of dirt sweat blood or anything
else you'd think he just spent the day
watching NFL red zone and not you know
blowing up a gorilla compound after
crawling in the dirt and sneaking
through the jungle for a couple hours
just wait
animal fake out jump scares are the most
annoying jump scares this is the
greatest squandering of ammo ever put to
film in under a minute good thing all
these weapons have the unlimited ammo
cheat code activated on them otherwise
shooting this much without a target in
sight might be considered wasteful this
prisoner girl that is somehow being held
captive with a couple zip ties is the
only one to see the glowing alien blood
on the leap and because she's seen
terrible decisions in sci-fi movies
before she's gonna touch that I'm bill
Duke and this is my sad face behold how
much it appears as if I am sat in order
to be as dexterous with these tools and
machines as possible what do you think
this creature might shave down those
finger claws a bit I'm just sayin
someone needs a pretty clear where's the
girl I could waste several minutes
debating which of these fools is more to
blame for the girl disappearing but
ultimately it's both of them you see the
trees um duh I don't know what don't uh
she speaks English but setting aside how
and why she speaks English why did she
wait so long to reveal it to her captors
there's no reason for Ana to suddenly
change and be helpful other than the
plot needed it to happen it's not like
Arnie even asked nicely
uh he did the old I pulled out my knife
and it seems like I might kill you but
I'm actually cutting a free trick bleeds
we can kill it yeah I guess I mean maybe
it wasn't blood at all maybe she saw
alien earwax or not maybe it was space
gasoline powering some kind of spacesuit
gizmo my point is jumping straight to
blood was silly jumping from the air
straight till we can kill it is
borderline certifiable it's our old pal
pretty up do during this oh so exciting
jungle snare setting montage was there
any reason for them or us to believe he
is watching them lay all these traps
she literally would from prisoner and
zip tie cuffs to speaks English now and
is helping with the physical labor stuff
in 60 seconds what makes you think he's
gonna come in through here there
tripwires and every tree for 50 yards
this is the only way in okay
first of all into what where you are
what makes you so certain that's after
you when it's spent all day watching you
build all these traps and everyone's
trying to kill you second of all you are
in a jungle you're not on like a skinny
pooping island or Peninsula
you're in a jungle I think could easily
go around and ignore your 50 yard trees
in this dialogue
almost offensive capital fails the law
summers means the demon who make straw
fish soft man we just call that the
Oscars touch touch double dutch look how
far out here Dutchess wandered beyond
their traps into the middle of the
supposed battlefield and nothing so the
predator either doesn't want to win or
doesn't want to win yet right sure
enough though after all these hours
spent sitting obvious traps out in the
open the predator does choose that
moment to show up like I think the
predator has a script credit that's how
well he knows the story beats um leave
it right you're fighting an alien that
complains in a forest background the
wounded are all on their own as far as
I'm concerned it didn't to lea because
it weren't armed no sports he's right
but it kind of ruins the fun that he's
right and there's no good reason he
should have figured that out on his own
anyway
but whatever movies gotta Arnold if the
predator is this visible while not even
moving how did it set off that trap
earlier right next to Dutch and he
didn't see it honestly once you know
what you're looking for I'm not sure
this camouflage would do all that much
good I'd take a severed arm continuing
to shoot a semi-automatic weapon as much
as the next guy but that finger
definitely came off the trigger when it
bounced that's it after all that Billy
build-up we don't even get to see
another unrealistic fight with outdated
visual effects you're really just gonna
schlock block us like that me what that
predator plasma cannon thingamajig blew
a hole the size of Minnesota and Jesse
Ventura and flew the right hook clean
off Apollo Creed so how was it leaving
Dutch here with just a flesh wound
classic Schwarzenegger line and all but
what exactly is she supposed to do when
she does indeed arrived at the choppa
oh hey guys no I'm just a local gal with
the blood of your colleagues all over my
shirt and all but I was distinctly told
to get to this here choppa wallboard
predator already shot him he's crawling
because the predator shot him so why is
the predator doing nothing right now
whilst he crawls towards a weapon as
Arnie flies off the edge you can clearly
see he is above the trees and rocks but
of course when he lands he has somehow
been transported to above water my
question is why even let the POV shot go
on long enough to see the ground below I
mean I know this was made at a time when
you were probably editing with rocks and
sticks and such but geez I make it so
obvious
this stuntman looks nothing like Arnold
and I think the movie is kind of rubbing
it in my face oh man here we go I'm
about done one of the coolest and most
iconic moments in movie history first of
all the
is almost certainly not cold enough to
lower or mask his body temperature
enough to make him invisible to the
predator second of all even if we're
cold enough you didn't coat his skin
fully or properly 30 even if the mud
were cold enough and evenly enough
applied all over touch from him crawling
on it how doesn't mean the predator
would be blind at Dutch it just means
the Dutch shape he sees is now a
different more blue color colder than
the branches and rocks or warmer and not
the same color as humans normally rain
but still the predator should see it
Dutch sized blob right in front of it
fourth what about his 15 eyeballs
doesn't at least some heat radiates from
the eyes what is the substance on me
that might have blinded my foe
I shall acquire some from my shoulder to
take a closer look so the audience knows
for sure why this happened the good news
is at least they didn't make him
actually verbalized couldn't see me damn
it if you knew the psychopathic alien
hunter was trying to track you down and
somehow figured out that mud kept him
from seeing you wouldn't you just
slather that stuff on before going
anywhere I'm just saying if it were me
I'd be so covered in mud it would look
like mr. Hankey was going on for a
jungle stroll you might think this is
where the movie went full home alone but
that only shows how young you are
because this movie is we're home alone
got all its initial ideas from home
alone was literally pitched as predator
with a kid in the suburbs also once
again very kind of the predator to piece
out for a long stretch of time so Dutch
can booby trap this section of the
jungle in broad daylight let's talk
about how Dutch tied this vine to this
log he wrapped it around one end over
and over and then tied a knot above that
and somehow that multi-ton log hasnt
simply fallen straight down out of that
not secure wraparound vine condom look
everyone Dutch made a fire at night in
the jungle when he knows an alien kill
bot with heat vision is hunting him hate
vision fire here in a bit when all his
traps are ready he's going to roar into
the jungle to draw the predator to it
and my point is why why would he ever
need to do that with this fucking signal
fire going yeah no unless he chose to
test fire that into the most rotten
deadest tree on planet earth this era
was a lot of all the evil things
predators have done I think killing a
platypus might be the evilest well even
if I buy that whole mud on your skin
thing applying it directly next to a
raging fire seems counterintuitive
also what is he looking at did he find a
mirror out here argh
I swear if Chris Hanson popped out right
now I'd take off 50 Cent's wouldn't all
these explosions be counterproductive
for the Predators heat vision probably
wouldn't whatever the predator version
of Smith and Wesson is have developed a
more non explosive weapon system oh no
the Predators unfair space laser is
broken that's too bad
it's breadcrumbs when the alien
antagonist is bleeding in intervals this
regular instead of easily killing him
here the predator traps his skull then
picks him up and throws him against a
tree then leaves him and walks away and
takes off his mask because he wants to
fight fair here at the end now that he's
fought unfair the whole movie to wipe
everyone else out an injured Dutch now
he wants to make sure it's mono he alien
and honestly he can crack the hell off
this does mean that the predator has
found a suitable mate right that's where
this seductive striptease is heading No
- some predator vision without the mask
looked like he still sees in heat vision
and other times it just looks completely
red if I didn't know better I think you
were just cycling through cool 80s video
effects and making it up as you go along
you don't have to read predator East I
know a good old-fashioned pointless bomb
countdown when you see one I want to be
the pupils government space this is the
when you absolutely positively got to
kill every mother in the room no
substitute what's your name I knew him
Horatio a fellow of Infinite Jest
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out